unsaddle line P and line Q which are on
a plane the lines are also parallel to
each other which would mean that they do
not intersect or ever meet and this is
transversal R which cuts the lines P and
Q at two distinct points in this video
we will try to understand the different
types of angles formed by the
transversal with two parallel lines the
transversal forms four angles with line
P angles 1 2 3 & 4 & 4 angles with line
Q angles 5 6 7 & 8 let's move on to the
first type of angles if lines P and Q
are parallel then angle 1 will always
equal angle 5 this angle here will be
equal to this one they are called
corresponding angles it does not matter
how the transversal is placed these
angles will always be equal on a new
page let us try moving the transversal
around assume line a and line B are
parallel to each other and here is a
transversal C you can see that these two
angles look equal now let's rotate the
transversal towards the right these two
angles again seem to be equal now let's
rotate the transversal towards the left
the angles become obtuse and are still
equal this tells us that the
corresponding angles are always equal
now let's go back to the previous page
now let me ask you an interesting
question look at the figure closely is
this the only pair of corresponding
angles no it isn't we have three more
pairs of corresponding angles when a
transversal intersects a pair of
parallel lines four pairs of
corresponding angles are formed two and
six form a corresponding angles pair so
angle two will always equal angle six
you can even look at the figure and
observe that they are equal similarly
angle three will equal angle seven and
angle four will equal angle eight
these are the four pairs of
corresponding angles that are formed 1 &
5 2 & 6 3 & 7 4 & 8 angles 3 4 5 & 6 are
interior angles because they are between
the two parallel lines and they are
classified into two types let's
understand the first type angle 3 and
angle 5 form a pair of alternate
interior angles we know why they are
called interior
but why exactly are they called
alternate if we have a round table with
numbers 3 4 5 & 6
around it then 5 is alternate to 3
that's because after 3 you skip 1
position and take the next similarly 6
will be alternate to 4 in this diagram
as well define alternate of 3 we skip 1
position and take the next which is 5
and similarly angle 4 and angle 6 are
also called
alternate interior angles this was the
first type of interior angles the second
type is a pair in which the angles are
next to each other on the same side of
the transversal like angle 3 and angle 6
they are called consecutive interior
angles look at the figure now do you see
any other pair of consecutive interior
angles yes with the same logic even
angles 4 & 5 are consecutive interior
angles
remember there are two types of interior
angles alternate and consecutive for
alternate we skip one and move to the
next four consecutive we take the one
that's immediately next to it and the
last types of angles that are formed are
vertically opposite angles angles 1 & 3
are called vertically opposite angles in
all there are 4 pairs of vertically
opposite angles
apart from angles 1 & 3 we have angles 2
& 4 angles 5 & 7 and angles 6 & 8 as the
other 3 pairs and vertically opposite
angles are always equal
these were the different types of angles
that were formed when a transversal
meets two parallel lines on a new page
let's look at the beauty of these angles
assume we have lines a and B which are
parallel and transversal C which
intersects them at two distinct points
as we already know the transversal forms
eight angles one two three four five six
seven and eight let us quickly analyze
the relation between various angles
formed it's pretty simple actually angle
two will be equal to angle six as their
corresponding angles an angle eight
equals angle six as it is vertically
opposite to it an angle four equals
angle eight because they are
corresponding angles
similarly angle one equals angle five as
their corresponding angles angle seven
equals angle five because they are
vertically opposite an angle three
equals angle seven because they are
corresponding angles so if lines a and B
are parallel we can see that angles one
three five and seven are equal and
angles two four six and eight are equal
you